where i was like oh my god yeah that
happened to me things like
you know stonewalling like silent
treatments or
um you know gaslighting
um all forms of manipulation crazy
making
like that to me feels like the most
obvious one is where you just go i i
you feel like you're going crazy um so
i'd love for you to kind of go into this
and hopefully
um tap into maybe something that
someone's hearing and
and can go you know like
so let's start with your most basic
example there which is the gas lighting
right
to have your reality denied gaslighting
isn't something that happens once and
you're all in right it's a grooming
process it happens over time
and it requires you to be in a
relationship that's characterized by
trust or some level of authority or
expertise
and a new relationship's an interesting
example of that because if you're
attracted to
various elements of the person how they
look and who they are and you really see
that there's a possibility for a
relationship
you want to trust them and when you want
to or you already trust someone and they
start gaslighting you you don't go right
to their gaslighting me
use the first thing most people do when
they're gaslighted is doubt themselves
like
maybe they're right maybe i am being too
sensitive or maybe i did read that
situation wrong or
maybe i didn't put the keys there or
maybe that didn't happen or maybe
they weren't being inappropriate with
that person and that happens
so it's not happening once or twice it's
happening dozens and then hundreds of
times
when a person's gaslighted they lose a
lot of their power in a situation
because they're spending so much time
saying huh what
and you start thinking like maybe my
memory's going maybe i need to see a
doctor
maybe i'm the one with the mental
illness maybe i'm the narcissist
you people go there now all of your time
is sort of almost trying to get back
your get your footing back
the gas lighter is controlling you more
and more and more
really insidious process and then before
you know it
what the gaslighter does it's an
interesting trick
let's say a person finds their voice and
it's like okay i've got this figured out
i watched one of dr romney's videos i
read something on gaslighting i got this
and you say something like you know what
like i
don't like how you're talking to me or
this i'm not comfortable with this you
know what the gaslighter will say
maybe you're not feeling this
relationship that more i get it like
we've been drifting apart
and they start threatening leaving they
play into a fear
that ironically even though narcissistic
people and gaslighters don't like
abandonment
they know it's the ultimate weapon and
now you're into the relationship six
nine twelve months maybe if it's new
you say i don't want this to break up i
wanted us to have a talk
and so you're silenced once again
because you feel like if i push this
conversation too much
they're going to feel like i'm pushing
back on the relationship and they're
criticized
and so maybe they're going to want out
so maybe i am making too big a deal out
of this
and you start gaslighting yourself and
then before long
the person is almost just living in the
gaslighted universe
they may give up on goals aspirations
they may talk to people less they may
give up friendships
they may give up all kinds of things in
their life to live in the universe that
the gaslighter created
and so now they're though to the world
it looks like the two of you are exactly
on the same page
you're not on the same page you're
almost like a cult member now you've
been totally brainwashed and you're
going along with the program
because otherwise you lose the
relationship which in my estimation
would have been the best outcome
but a lot of people aren't ready for
that that's the process
yeah this is that's the sort of like
what i would describe
in my experience was the destabilization
like that's the destabilization where
you just kind of feel like you're on
your back heels and you're just like oh
you're just trying to hang on like you
don't
quite understand what's going on you're
confused you know
and yeah and that's that's a that's a
destabilizing situation
so um let's talk about um like
stonewalling or silent trees right then
so the silent treatment is a
very popular tool of people in
narcissistic relationships
because it is very manipulative right
to give someone the silent treatment is
very it's very
punitive because you are literally feel
like you're now living in an alternative
universe there's two of you in the
kitchen and they're not saying a word to
you
you're passing like chips in the night
you're standing next to each other
brushing your teeth
they are saying nothing to you this
doesn't just happen in intimate
relationships it can happen in families
you may go to a family gathering and
people there's
one person just literally they'll say
hey can you
pass the butter and you're the one next
to the butter and
and people will all be looking and yeah
someone's reaching over
because they won't talk to you so it is
very punitive now think about what the
silent treatment ends up getting you
them
though what does it get them you end up
breaking and often say i'm sorry
and they get an apology usually for
something you didn't do wrong
and they hold the power so one could
even argue the silent treatment is sort
of like a satellite of gaslighting
but it's extremely unhealthy it's very
different for a person to say listen
i can feel the steam coming up in me i'm
going to go take a walk
i'm going to go clear my head i'm going
to go do what i need to do but then you
come back and talk to the person
the silent treatment is punishment and
it's a manipulation
and that's a common common tool
something you're calling stonewalling
it's similar to the silent treatment but
it's a little bit of a variation on a
theme
stonewalling is i'm not going to talk
about this anymore
we're not doing this again or just
walking out
because what they've said is i'm not
even going to permit this discourse
it's not you know and so now you're
being told you don't get to bring up
parts of your emotional world a
discomfort about something like that's
all
you know no-fly zones so now your
relationship has all these little sort
of marks on it where
you can't go there because we're not
doing this we're not talking about this
that's stonewalling now some people
argue that narcissists stonewall because
a topic is about to bring up their shame
so they just say i'm putting a stop to
this and there are people like john
gottman who
who talks about marriage and has done
probably some of the most comprehensive
research on this
and to him stonewalling is one of sort
of the you know the death knells of a
relationship if you're engaging in
stonewalling you're sort of at that you
know you're really
coming towards the end and then danica
there are other patterns like um baiting
narcissistic people love a fight and so
you're thinking like why do they say
things just to get me worked up i'm like
to get you worked up they do it's so
it's like it's their
it would be like their narcissistic
supply i feel like the drama the chaos
the anger the fear the sadness that
comes out of you is their supply
like once that once there's no more
reaction anymore
they aren't getting supply it's like
they just need energy
they not only need but they need energy
but they also need this which is
superiority
so let's say you generally well put
together they bait you
and you're like and you take the bait
now you're like
you're screaming and yelling and now the
narcissist actually calms down
almost instantly your madness completely
calms them down it's like a tranquilizer
for them and they're like
goodness my isn't somebody getting a
little worked up you need to you're a
little crazy you need to calm down
and that's gaslighting because now
you've been painted as this thing you're
not
but you have literally been baited so
it's about training yourself to not take
the bait